Hi I'm Jack, I'm from the great city of Norwich in the UK that I'm actually talking from the middle of Tokyo in the early hours.
大家好，我是杰克，我来自英国伟大的诺里奇市，实际上我是在凌晨在东京市中心讲话的。
What how I make a mother means to me?
如何成为一名母亲对我来说意味着什么？
It's the emphasis on hindsight, the benefit of hindsight and the fact that as bleak and as negative as things may seem in the moment, actually it may be building to something better.
它强调事后诸葛亮，事后诸葛亮的好处，以及这样一个事实：尽管目前的情况看起来很黯淡和消极，但实际上它可能正在走向更好的方向。
made me set me new on a course in your life, which ultimately leads something better.
让我为你的人生开辟了新的道路，最终带来更好的东西。
That means a lot, simply because I, about eight months ago, I had a nervous breakdown.
这意义重大，仅仅因为我，大约八个月前，我精神崩溃了。
I wasn't very happy with my life.
我对自己的生活不太满意。
And here I am eight months now, I'm from that now, and I'm much happier where I am.
我现在已经八个月了，我已经摆脱了那个状态，而且我对现在的处境感到更加高兴。
I'm in Tokyo for the first time, and I might be in a position to tell the girl that I love that I love her.
我第一次来东京，我可能有能力告诉那个女孩我爱她。
so and actually seriously thank you for that it's really helped thinking about it and watching the program I don't think you can be emphasised just how much it means to people and how much it means to me I don't know how to thank you for that except for this message Well, hello there, I'm Josh Ratner, I am joined by my friend Craig Thomas for another episode of How We Made Your Mother, Hi Craig.
所以，实际上，我真的很感谢你，因为它对思考这个问题和观看这个节目确实有帮助，我认为你无法强调它对人们的意义有多大，对我的意义有多大。除了这条消息，我不知道如何感谢你。好吧，你好，我是乔什·拉特纳，我和我的朋友克雷格·托马斯一起观看了《我们如何创造了你的母亲》的另一集，嗨克雷格。
Hey Josh.
嘿乔什。
Hey.
嘿。
Boy.
男生。
I don't, maybe one of these openings won't, well, I won't get choked up as it's happening, but I'm 0 for 12 or whatever it is, and not getting choked up.
我不，也许其中一个空缺不会，好吧，当它发生时我不会被哽咽，但我是 12 或其他什么的 0，并且不会被哽咽。
It's always an amazing way to start the show because this is our first time hearing them.
这总是一个令人惊奇的开始演出的方式，因为这是我们第一次听到他们。
So it kind of puts you on your back foot in a good way, right?
所以这会让你处于不利地位，对吗？
like, I don't come on knowing what we're going to hear, how I'm going to respond to it.
就像，我不知道我们会听到什么，也不知道我将如何回应。
What Jack was saying so, so beautifully.
杰克说得如此美妙。
And I think the thing about, I think the medicine, if you could distill what, how I met your mother, the special medicine that it has within it, that people keep going back to it as if it's some kind of like, well, or altar, some sort of like nourishing, life-giving thing, is It doesn't shy away from the low moments, but it gives you this context for viewing the tough stuff in life that says, no, you know, a lot of times you have to be broken, open, so something else can come in.
我认为，我认为药物，如果你能提炼出什么，我是如何遇见你母亲的，它里面有一种特殊的药物，人们不断地回到它，就好像它是某种类似的东西，好，或者祭坛，某种像滋养的、赋予生命的东西，它不会回避低潮时刻，但它给你一个背景来看待生活中的艰难事物，它说，不，你知道，很多时候你必须被打破，开放，所以一些东西别的可以进来。
And the old parts of you have to die and go away and wither before the new thing can regenerate and grow.
在新的事物能够再生和成长之前，你的旧部分必须死亡、消失和枯萎。
And you know, I was listening to him and I was like, wow, I need to hear this today.
你知道，我听他讲话时就想，哇，我今天需要听听这个。
Like, I'm glad you said that, you know?
就像，我很高兴你这么说，你知道吗？
Me too.
我也是。
And I'm just, as you know, winding down my tour and I have certain songs that I'm so glad I wrote them because I get to sing them all the time and I get to hear them again.
正如你所知，我只是在结束我的巡演，我有一些歌曲我很高兴我写了它们，因为我可以一直唱它们，并且可以再次听到它们。
I get to hear them anew.
我重新听到他们的声音。
And even working on this show with you, Craig and Alec and everyone else is like, it's just refreshing that message within me, you know, and it's so much, it's bigger than how I your mother, but I think how I met your mother did such a good job at creating, spinning a narrative where people could get, you know, literally punched in the face.
即使是和你、克雷格、亚历克和其他人一起制作这个节目，这也只是刷新了我内心的信息，你知道，它比我你母亲的形象更重要，但我认为我是如何遇见你母亲的，在创造、编造一个人们可能会被打在脸上的叙事方面做得很好。
It was all part of some big plan.
这都是某个大计划的一部分。
I mean, it's really, it's quite magical.
我的意思是，这真的非常非常神奇。
Well, it's interesting.
嗯，这很有趣。
There's this idea of the one, right?
有这个想法，对吗？
I'm going to hold on to meet the one.
我会坚持下去，去见那个人。
And that is a beautiful thing, right?
这是一件美好的事情，对吧？
That aspiration, that romantic idea of meeting the one.
那种渴望，那种遇见那个人的浪漫想法。
But what I took from Jack's message, and I think it is in the show too, maybe even as much or more built into the structure of the show, is that when you're in a low moment, you should also hold on for future you.
但我从杰克的信息中得到的信息是，当你处于低潮时刻时，你也应该为未来的自己坚持下去，而且我认为这也在节目中体现出来，甚至可能更多地融入到节目的结构中。
That's who you're doing it for.
这就是你为之做事的人。
You're holding out an enduring for them so they can get through it.
你为他们提供了持久的支持，以便他们能够度过难关。
You can meet them later.
你可以稍后再见到他们。
You can meet future you and tell the story.
你可以遇见未来的你并讲述故事。
That's who you owe it to.
那是你欠谁的。
That's who you're doing it for.
这就是你为之做事的人。
And it's almost like future me is gonna need some resilience.
未来的我几乎需要一些韧性。
They're gonna need the lessons and strength that I'm gathering now.
他们需要我现在正在收集的教训和力量。
Because it might even be harder in the future.
因为未来可能会更加困难。
It's like, I need to, I'm in training for my future self.
就像，我需要，我正在为未来的自己进行训练。
And presumably maybe your kids, I think there's that kind of like, there's the storyline of parents' sacrifice for their children.
想必也许你的孩子，我认为有这样的故事情节，父母为孩子做出牺牲。
And we sacrifice for our future selves.
我们为未来的自己做出牺牲。
Like it's a really, that's quite a lovely idea.
就像这是一个真的，这是一个非常可爱的主意。
I love that, Craig.
我喜欢这个，克雷格。
Yeah, I mean, I really heard that in what Jack said there.
是的，我的意思是，我确实从杰克那里听到了这一点。
So, Jack, thank you.
所以，杰克，谢谢你。
Thanks for reminding us of that part of the show we made that maybe we weren't aware of at the time in a way.
感谢您提醒我们我们制作的节目中可能在某种程度上我们当时没有意识到的部分。
And also like, how I met your mother is very much about a man in dialogue with himself.
还有，我是如何认识你母亲的，很大程度上是一个男人与自己对话的过程。
Yeah, it is that there's a, certainly the older narrator Ted is in dialogue with this younger self, but on some cosmic weird level, present day Ted, My Ted, the Ted I played, is also in dialogue with his older self because he's always thinking about the front porch down the line and what I'm going to be.
是的，确实有一个，年长的叙述者泰德正在与年轻的自己对话，但在某种宇宙奇怪的层面上，现在的泰德，我的泰德，我扮演的泰德，也在与他年长的自己对话，因为他总是在思考未来的前廊和我将成为什么样的人。
He's trying to lay the seeds for his life.
他正在努力为自己的人生埋下种子。
And he's mistake prone and he draws erroneous conclusions quite a bit, but he ultimately does string it together.
他很容易犯错误，并且得出了很多错误的结论，但他最终确实把它们串在一起了。
And I think there's something about the show that's quite forgiving.
我认为这部剧有一些相当宽容的地方。
There's a mercy at the heart of it that I think people really respond to like it's okay to make mistakes, it's okay to, you know, it's okay to have a breakdown as Jack said.
它的核心是一种仁慈，我认为人们真的会做出这样的反应，就像犯错误是可以的，你知道，正如杰克所说，崩溃是可以的。
And then before, you know, eight months, eight months is not that long to kind of like swing to the other way.
然后之前，你知道，八个月，八个月并没有那么长，就像转向另一条路一样。
So it's like, it gives people faith.
所以就像，它给了人们信心。
I mean, what better thing would you hope for from a television show?
我的意思是，您希望从电视节目中得到什么更好的东西？
Yeah, it's an honor and a privilege to hear that it meant that to Jack and other people, it's amazing.
是的，我很荣幸听到这对杰克和其他人来说意味着，这真是太棒了。
And that is the aspirational quality of the show.
这就是该剧令人向往的品质。
It seems at first that it's the aspiration of meeting the one, but in a way it's also just surviving and telling, realizing you're becoming the person who's going to tell this story one day, which I loved head for because that's his drive.
乍一看，这似乎是与那个人见面的愿望，但在某种程度上，这也只是生存和讲述，意识到你有一天会成为讲述这个故事的人，我喜欢走向这个，因为这是他的动力。
That's really his drive.
这确实是他的动力。
Yeah.
是的。
Well, let's downshift into the episode under discussion this week.
好吧，让我们进入本周讨论的情节。
This episode embodies a lot of what we just talked about.
这一集体现了我们刚才谈到的很多内容。
Yeah, it really does.
是的，确实如此。
And this is kind of, we've been talking about this.
这就是我们一直在谈论的。
This is kind of part one of a really like a two-part episode around this wedding, this episode, the wedding, which is episode 12, is that right, Alec?
这是围绕这场婚礼的两集剧集的第一部分，这一集是婚礼，即第 12 集，是吗，亚历克？
Yes.
是的。
Yeah.
And when did this episode air?
而这一集什么时候播出呢？
This episode first aired on January 9th, 2006.
本集于2006年1月9日首播。
Okay.
好的。
Our first one of the new year.
我们新年的第一个。
and then this led into drum roll, please, episode 13.
然后就进入了第 13 集，请打鼓。
But let's limit our discussion at least for now to the wedding.
但至少现在我们的讨论仅限于婚礼。
You wanna give it- It will be hard.
你想给它——这会很难。
I bid you one last night.
昨晚我给你打了一个。
I watched him as an hour and it plays so great as an hour that it will be really hard not to talk about it as well.
我看了他一个小时，他的表现非常棒，以至于我很难不去谈论它。
I made a huge mistake watching both together, even though I loved it.
尽管我很喜欢，但我还是犯了一个巨大的错误。
I loved the hour of this, but we'll talk about the first half hour and then we'll get to this.
我很喜欢这一个小时，但我们先讨论前半个小时，然后再讨论这个。
Well, do you wanna do our quick summary as best you can of what happens in this episode of the wedding.
好吧，您想尽可能快速地总结一下本期婚礼中发生的事情吗？
Yeah, I mean, it's exactly what we just talked about.
是的，我的意思是，这正是我们刚才谈到的。
It's Ted making a plan, coming up with an idea and an aspiration.
泰德正在制定计划，提出想法和愿望。
He's gonna bring Robin and his embassy.
他会带罗宾和他的大使馆来。
And that has to be exactly the way he sees it.
他一定也这么认为。
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah, it's actually quite like the one of which preceded it in a way where it's like the plan and then watch the plan fall to absolute shit.
是的，它实际上很像之前的计划，在某种程度上就像计划一样，然后看着计划彻底崩溃。
And then maybe something better emerges out of that.
然后也许会出现更好的东西。
It's a similar structure.
这是一个类似的结构。
But Ted wants, Ted wants to bring, Ted's feelings for Robin have crept back up, right?
但泰德想要，泰德想要带来，泰德对罗宾的感情已经慢慢恢复了，对吗？
And we saw it start in pineapple incident.
我们看到它从菠萝事件开始。
We saw it when they kissed at the end of the limo, we saw some heat there.
当他们在豪华轿车的末端接吻时，我们看到了这一点，我们看到那里有一些热量。
We saw those embers are starting to catch a little, let's turn this little smoke coming out of there again.
我们看到那些余烬开始燃烧，让我们再次转动从那里冒出来的小烟。
And Ted says, I think I have feelings for Robin again.
特德说，我想我又对罗宾产生了感情。
And he wants to bring her to this wedding that they're all going to.
他想带她参加他们都要参加的婚礼。
And Ted is convinced he did his thing he always does, which is checking plus one out of this aspirational hope that when he got the wedding invitation and he looked ahead a few months, he would have this belief that he would be in love with somebody and bringing that person.
泰德确信他做了他一直做的事情，即检查加一出于这种渴望，当他收到婚礼邀请函并展望未来几个月时，他会相信他会爱上某人并带来那个人。
And I love how the whole episode kind of becomes this symposium on is Ted the kind of guy who always checks that box out of his feeling that he's a couple guy, or is Barney actually right when Barney says, you didn't check that box.
我喜欢整个情节如何成为这个研讨会的主题，泰德是那种总是勾选那个框的人，因为他觉得自己是情侣，或者当巴尼说，你没有勾选那个框时，巴尼实际上是对的。
You check that you were going solo because you knew you were going to go there with me and we're going to hook up with bridesmaids and whatever.
你检查一下你是否要单独去，因为你知道你会和我一起去那里，我们会和伴娘什么的勾搭上。
And I love that the whole episode is kind of this like court case essentially about which guy is Ted.
我喜欢整个情节有点像法庭案件，本质上是关于哪个人是特德。
And of course, in the end, we find out that I was just spoilers that Barney is right, Ted did not check that, which I think is really, really interesting that Ted did not check at that one.
当然，最后我们发现我只是剧透巴尼是对的，特德没有检查这一点，我认为这真的非常有趣，泰德没有检查这一点。
And it's a weird thing, again, like how memory plays with us and toys with us, you know, like I'm certain I checked that, you know, because I'm the kind of guy, it also is very field of dreams, you know, this idea of like you build it, they will come, right?
这又是一件奇怪的事情，就像记忆如何与我们玩耍，如何与我们玩耍，你知道，就像我确信我检查过一样，你知道，因为我是那种人，它也是一个非常梦想的领域，你知道，这个想法就像你建造它一样，他们会来，对吗？
Like totally.
完全喜欢。
He's a man of, you know, he's really wanting to, he's wanting to, he's wanting to create space for this other person, but something in him is like self-sabotaging.
他是一个，你知道的，他真的很想要，他想要，他想要为另一个人创造空间，但他身上有些东西就像自我破坏。
And it's even mystifying to him, right?
这甚至让他感到困惑，对吧？
There's a thing you want to know.
有件事你想知道。
You want to know if Ted checked that box or not, and you do get to find the answer in the end of the episode.
你想知道特德是否选中了该框，并且你确实可以在剧集的结尾找到答案。
I really likes that.
我真的很喜欢这样。
Hey, I'm Carl Radke.
嘿，我是卡尔·拉德克。
You might know me from Bravo's Summer House, but on my podcast, More Life, I get your favorite reality stars off the clock, and into the conversations you don't usually get to hear.
您可能在 Bravo's Summer House 认识我，但在我的播客 More Life 中，我会不分昼夜地邀请您最喜欢的真人秀明星，并参与您通常听不到的对话。
The deep stuff, the vulnerable stuff, the uncomfortable stuff.
深层的东西，脆弱的东西，不舒服的东西。
I've sat down with Sierra Miller, Derinda Medley, Tom Schwartz, Lindsey Hubbard, and a whole lot more.
我与塞拉·米勒 (Sierra Miller)、德林达·梅德利 (Derinda Medley)、汤姆·施瓦茨 (Tom Schwartz)、林赛·哈伯德 (Lindsey Hubbard) 等人进行了交谈。
We get into relationships growing up, the messy stuff, and everything that happens when the cameras aren't rolling.
我们在成长过程中会陷入人际关系，遇到混乱的事情，以及摄像机不转动时发生的一切。
New episodes of More Life every week, listen wherever you get your podcasts or watch on YouTube.
More Life 每周都有新剧集，无论您在哪里收听播客或在 YouTube 上观看。
And now, back to the show.
现在，回到节目。
You know, this episode is really, really good.
你知道，这一集真的非常非常好。
And I also, So, Jordana has remarked that to her, the show's getting funnier as she watches it, but I think that's a consequence of, you know, you know, the characters a little bit deeper, and when they respond as their character would respond, there's pleasure in it, right?
我也，所以，乔丹娜对她说，随着她的观看，这部剧变得越来越有趣，但我认为这是因为，你知道，你知道，角色有点深入，当他们像他们的角色一样做出反应时，就会有乐趣，对吧？
Because you're like, oh, that's old so-and-so.
因为你就像，哦，那是老某某。
Like, that sounds just like, you know, Marshall loves the cake.
就像，这听起来就像，你知道，马歇尔喜欢蛋糕。
Oh, he's a cake lover.
哦，他是个蛋糕爱好者。
You know, like, I actually jumped ahead.
你知道，我实际上已经领先了。
And I had some notes that I warned you feel like the ravings of a madman, because I watched this for week ago.
我有一些笔记，我警告你感觉像个疯子的胡言乱语，因为我一周前看过这个。
Do you remember writing these notes?
你还记得写过这些笔记吗？
I don't.
我不知道。
Do you go on this sort of a fugue state?
你会进入这种神游状态吗？
I was on so much tantrum.
我当时非常发脾气。
I have no memory.
我没有记忆。
It was just a tantrum and sandwich weekend.
这只是一个发脾气和吃三明治的周末。
What is Dear Carcasson a hunting trip?
亲爱的卡尔卡森狩猎之旅是什么？
That is.
那是。
Okay.
好的。
This is good.
这很好。
We're going to make a little game show out of this one.
我们将用这个制作一个小游戏节目。
I'm going to try to...
我要尝试...
The game is me translating Josh's...
这个游戏是我翻译乔什的......
The game is a fun.
游戏很有趣。
I have the answer to this one.
我有这个问题的答案。
The answer is, Barney says you do not bring a date to a wedding, because it's like bringing a deer cart to 100 groups, which is the creepiest possible metaphor.
答案是，巴尼说你不要带约会对象去参加婚礼，因为这就像给 100 群人带来一辆鹿车，这是最令人毛骨悚然的比喻。
Barney is clearly a murderer.
巴尼显然是凶手。
Barney has a murder house somewhere.
巴尼在某处有一处谋杀屋。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
That's what that one was.
就是那个。
And you write that down because you heard it, and at the time you think you were so disturbed by that image that you wanted to ask about it, or you don't even remember.
你把它写下来，因为你听到了，当时你认为你对那个图像感到非常不安，所以你想询问它，或者你甚至不记得了。
You have no recollection of it.
你对此没有任何记忆。
I remember just being startled by it.
我记得我只是被它吓了一跳。
Like, it's a startling image.
就像，这是一个令人震惊的图像。
It's a startling image.
这是一个令人震惊的画面。
As I think they point out to Barney and the moment too, to be fair.
公平地说，我认为他们也向巴尼和此时此刻指出了这一点。
I really like, this is another, I'm trying to get in the habit of seeing when I think I did a good job.
我真的很喜欢，这是另一个，我正在努力养成看我认为自己做得很好的习惯。
It's a self-esteem builder, right?
这是一个自尊建设者，对吧？
Yes, let's do it.
是的，让我们开始吧。
I love Ted's face when he hears that Robin and Derek broke up.
我喜欢泰德听到罗宾和德里克分手时的表情。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
The Christmas morning, I'm trying to hide the Christmas morning.
圣诞节的早晨，我试图隐藏圣诞节的早晨。
Look, I've said right.
你看，我说得对。
It's really fun as an actor to play two things at one.
作为一名演员同时扮演两件事真的很有趣。
It's fun to play the thing and then cover it, or cover it not that well, because of course he has to be like, oh, like a good friend, but the twinkle in his eye is like, yes, you know?
玩这个东西然后掩盖它，或者掩盖得不太好，这很有趣，因为他当然必须像，哦，像一个好朋友，但他眼中的闪烁就像，是的，你知道吗？
It is an A plus reaction shot.
这是一张 A+ 反应镜头。
It is a full on A plus reaction shot.
这是一张完整的 A+ 反应镜头。
I turned, I was watching with Rebecca and my wife and I said, that is a great, what Josh just did there.
我转过身来，我正在和丽贝卡和我的妻子一起观看，我说，乔什刚才所做的太棒了。
That little, I was gonna single that moment out too, it was great.
那一点，我也想挑出那一刻，那太棒了。
Good job, Josh.
干得好，乔什。
Well, it's also good work there.
嗯，那里的工作也很好。
It's also nice that you and Sue, you know, included that.
你知道，你和苏也加入了这一点，这也很好。
Like it's important, like, to clock.
就像时钟很重要一样。
This is his receipt.
这是他的收据。
Let's say that.
这么说吧。
Let's talk about that for a second.
让我们讨论一下这个问题。
Sue, our editor, who won, I believe three Emmys for how I met your mother, was one of her superpowers as an editor is that she just knew your guys' energy so well.
苏，我们的编辑，我相信她因我如何遇见你母亲而获得了三项艾美奖，她作为编辑的超能力之一是她非常了解你们的能量。
She knew the cast.
她认识演员阵容。
She really watched everything.
她真的什么都看在眼里。
She mentally lobbed things.
她在心里抛掷东西。
And she, so when her first first assembly cuts come in before we started honing it more.
还有她，所以当她的第一次装配削减出现时，我们才开始进一步打磨它。
So much good stuff was in there.
里面有那么多好东西。
She really attuned, she's a musician.
她真的很合拍，她是一位音乐家。
Sue, before she was an editor was a exceptional violinist in orchestra.
苏在担任编辑之前是一位杰出的管弦乐队小提琴家。
Or violist, yeah.
或者中提琴手，是的。
Violist.
中提琴家。
And she, God, now I'm up in my head about which one it was.
而她，上帝，现在我已经在想到底是哪一位了。
Sue, I forgive me, forgive us all if you got this wrong.
苏，如果你做错了，我原谅我，原谅我们大家。
But she was, she had a music to her and she attuned to what you guys were doing so acutely.
但她是，她有自己的音乐，她对你们所做的事情如此敏锐地适应。
So we, she would not waste that reaction.
所以我们，她不会浪费这个反应。
I bet that was in her first assembly.
我敢打赌那是她第一次集会。
She wouldn't sound like that.
她听起来不会那样。
You can make a case that Sue Federman knew the show better than anyone.
你可以证明苏·费德曼比任何人都更了解这个节目。
Yeah.
是的。
Do you know what I'm saying?
你知道我在说什么吗？
She saw the 35-minute cut and she helped whittle it down to the 22.
她看到了 35 分钟的剪辑，并帮助将其削减到 22 分钟。
Oh, longer sometimes.
哦，有时会更长。
So she saw every take.
所以她看到了每一个镜头。
Right?
正确的？
Yep.
是的。
I mean, she really got, and I think she, it was funny.
我的意思是，她真的做到了，而且我认为她，这很有趣。
I remember when Sue would come to set, she would pop in every once in a while, and she would always, you know, she clearly loved this gig.
我记得当苏来片场时，她会时不时地出现，而且她总是，你知道，她显然很喜欢这个演出。
Like, this was a job she really enjoyed.
就像，这是她真正喜欢的工作。
And you could, you know, she always made us feel so good because she would say, I'm just having the best time, just having the best time at you guys, you know?
你可以，你知道，她总是让我们感觉很好，因为她会说，我只是度过了最美好的时光，只是和你们一起度过了最美好的时光，你知道吗？
And that was such a nice feeling because before you saw the Final Cut, you were like, oh, the person who's got their eyes on this first is really likes this, you know?
那真是一种很好的感觉，因为在你看到最终剪辑之前，你会想，哦，第一个看到这个的人真的很喜欢这个，你知道吗？
She loved you guys and loved the show and like really got it.
她爱你们，也喜欢这个节目，而且真的很明白。
And what a superpower to have that on the roster, right?
名单上有这样的人真是一个超级大国，对吧？
I mean, like, at every, we had the right person at every job on this show, which doesn't always happen.
我的意思是，就像，在这个节目中，我们的每项工作都有合适的人选，但这并不总是发生。
And yeah, what a lucky thing.
是的，真是一件幸运的事。
So those little moments, they don't get lost.
所以那些小时刻，他们不会迷失。
Those little moments can see it.
那些微小的时刻可以看到它。
When did Barney say, how way, way, way?
巴尼什么时候说过，怎么样，怎么样，怎么样？
What was that?
那是什么？
I wrote that one.
我写了那一篇。
How way, way, way.
怎么样，怎么样，怎么样。
Alec, do you remember?
亚历克，你还记得吗？
We all watched this one day to go, less than 24 hours ago.
不到 24 小时前，我们都在前一天观看了这一集。
I'm blanking on that one thinking I bet people listening.
我对这个问题一片空白，认为我敢打赌人们会听。
No, this is the word is the first really the worst podcast of all time.
不，这个词是有史以来第一个真正最糟糕的播客。
It's not remembering what they watched 18 hours ago.
它不记得他们18小时前看过什么。
Not just watch, but guys wrote it rewrote it.
不仅仅是观看，而且人们写了它并重写了它。
Look, it's about the fallibility of memory.
看，这是关于记忆的错误。
This show is about the fallibility.
这个节目是关于错误的。
But it made me laugh.
但这让我笑了。
It made me laugh.
这让我笑了。
How way way way.
怎么样怎么样。
Oh my God, I'm blanking.
天哪，我脑子一片空白。
Yeah, this is embarrassing.
是的，这很尴尬。
What maybe next time when you do notes, you can draw pictures right down time, like so What was it?
也许下次当你做笔记时，你可以立即画图，就像这样，那是什么？
Is it Stewart who says you called our seven-year-old flower girl a whore or is that?
是斯图尔特说你称我们七岁的花童为妓女还是真的？
Yes, yes, that's a secret line.
是的，是的，这是一条秘密线路。
So I want to shout out Stuart and Claudia Virginia Williams, Matt Boren, who They were so good.
所以我想大声喊出斯图尔特和克劳迪娅·弗吉尼亚·威廉姆斯、马特·博伦，他们太棒了。
A bunch of times over the years, right?
这么多年，也有好几次了吧？
Yeah, they came back a bunch of times, but I will say I don't want to cut you off, Josh.
是的，他们回来了很多次，但我想说我不想打断你，乔什。
If there's no go ahead Here's my observation.
如果没有继续下去，这是我的观察。
Rebecca said this is rewatching it.
丽贝卡说这是重看。
First of all, I want to say I love them and I love this episode and I love the hour that is this sort of two-parter.
首先，我想说我爱他们，我喜欢这一集，我喜欢这种两人合作的时刻。
It reminded me a lot about the pilot and Purple Giraffe when you rewatch those.
当你重看这些时，它让我想起了很多关于飞行员和紫色长颈鹿的事情。
It really is an hour.
确实是一个小时了。
It really is like one episode, the wedding and drum roll.
这真的就像一集，婚礼和鼓乐。
I'm having such a hard time not talking about drum roll already in this podcast because it feels of a piece.
我很难不在这个播客中谈论鼓声，因为它感觉像是一个片段。
But Stuart and Claudia, It's very funny how in this episode, they just seem like they're the best friends of this group that you've never heard about until now.
但是斯图尔特和克劳迪娅，很有趣的是，在这一集里，他们似乎是这个团体中最好的朋友，而你以前从未听说过。
And then you go a long way, never hearing about them again.
然后你就走了很长一段路，再也没有听说过他们。
And when the wedding, the moment where the wedding falls apart, they've broken up as a couple.
当婚礼举行时，婚礼破裂的那一刻，他们作为情侣就分手了。
Who does Claudia call?
克劳迪娅给谁打电话？
She calls Lily.
她给莉莉打电话。
Lily is not in her vital party.
莉莉不在她的重要聚会中。
Lily's not her maid of honor.
莉莉不是她的伴娘。
She's like, who's the one person I can talk about this?
她说，谁是我可以谈论这件事的人？
Lily!
百合！
And it's just, it's very funny how much emphasis but I was like, Stuart and Claudia.
只是，非常有趣的是，我对斯图尔特和克劳迪娅的重视程度很高。
I was just, we really built that up.
我只是，我们真的建立了它。
We really explained how they all knew each other.
我们确实解释了他们是如何认识的。
We just sort of like created this condition.
我们只是创造了这个条件。
They're all really close.
他们都非常接近。
That's my one note on the episode.
这是我对这一集的一个注释。
My other note on the episode is, there's a moment in the episode where Lily has to be, is like, I'll go run out of the bar and comfort Claudia.
我对这一集的另一个注意事项是，在这一集中，莉莉必须有一个时刻，就像，我会跑出酒吧并安慰克劳迪娅。
You guys go talk some sense in a Stuart, or Marshall says, let's go talk sense in a Stuart.
你们去谈谈斯图亚特的一些道理，或者马歇尔说，让我们去谈谈斯图亚特的道理。
And the guys get to Stuart hours before Lily gets right downstairs to the bar.
在莉莉下楼去酒吧之前几个小时，他们就到达了斯图尔特。
Rebecca was like, why is, why is there such a lag for Lily getting down the bar?
丽贝卡心想，为什么，为什么莉莉从酒吧下来的速度这么慢？
And she's like, what happened there?
她说，那里发生了什么事？
And I was like, I don't know.
我当时想，我不知道。
I guess maybe she's taking a giant dump or something.
我猜她可能正在大便或其他什么东西。
That was my best.
那是我最好的。
I don't know.
我不知道。
She was trying to keep because Lily was always being first season.
她试图保留，因为莉莉总是在第一季。
It takes Lily a really long time to, if Barney has plenty of time to try to get, to get, you know, work his moves on Claudia.
如果巴尼有足够的时间去尝试，你知道，莉莉要花很长时间才能对克劳迪娅采取行动。
And we really, if we had it in the script or the cut, we definitely didn't keep it in the air episode that aired.
我们真的，如果我们在剧本或剪辑中包含它，我们绝对不会将其保留在播出的剧集中。
Was there, did we ever talk about an obstacle of why Lillie didn't make it down there faster?
我们有没有讨论过莉莉为什么不能更快地到达那里的障碍？
I can't remember.
我不记得了。
You know, speaking of the back of the script, friend groups, I have three very good friends, two of whom are married, but they're, they're just like my nearest and dearest, these people.
你知道，说到剧本后面的朋友群体，我有三个非常好的朋友，其中两个已经结婚了，但他们就像我最亲近的人，这些人。
And we call ourselves the Cirque, right?
我们称自己为马戏团，对吗？
Like we're the circle, the four of us we play together, like we're, and people who get close to us are like, can I be in the Cirque?
就像我们是一个圆圈，我们四个人一起玩，就像我们一样，接近我们的人会问，我可以加入马戏团吗？
We were like, oh, no, never, but we have a name for the people on the outside of the circle.
我们说，哦，不，从来没有，但我们对圈外的人有一个名字。
We call it the riff for the periphery.
我们称其为外围即兴演奏。
Like you're on the, you're kind of, the riff.
就像你在即兴演奏一样。
We say, what do you think, you can be in the riff, you know?
我们说，你觉得怎么样，你可以参加即兴演奏，你知道吗？
So Stuart and Claudia were in the riff, but they would never be in the surf.
所以斯图尔特和克劳迪娅在即兴演奏中，但他们永远不会在冲浪中。
They were never gonna be in the surf.
他们永远不会去冲浪。
Yeah, they're in the riff, but yeah, they're not.
是的，他们在即兴演奏中，但是，是的，他们不是。
It's just so funny that that's the person that like Claudia It's like, I've got to talk to Lily right now.
真是太有趣了，那个人喜欢克劳迪娅，就像，我现在必须和莉莉谈谈。
And there was something funny about that when we were watching it.
当我们观看它时，有一些有趣的事情。
But they're so, they're both so perfectly cast because Virginia had a way of being kind of like a bridezilla but not in a way that was like odious.
但他们就是这样，他们都是如此完美的演员，因为弗吉尼亚有一种有点像新娘的方式，但又不像令人讨厌的方式。
It was more like, no, she has a point, like you can't do this.
更像是，不，她有道理，就像你不能这样做。
That is fucking stuff up in here a little bit, right?
这里有点他妈的东西，对吧？
You do not fuck with a bride.
你不能和新娘上床。
That is definitely fucking stuff up there.
那绝对是他妈的东西。
I also watch this now 20 years.
我现在也看这个20年了。
I haven't seen this in 20 years.
我已经 20 年没见过这个了。
You've gotten married since then.
从那时起你们就结婚了。
I've gotten married at a wedding.
我在婚礼上结婚了。
Like I understand like if someone calls you two days before the wedding and they're like, can I bring a date?
就像我理解的那样，如果有人在婚礼前两天打电话给你，他们会说，我可以带一个约会对象吗？
It's like, are you insane?
就像，你疯了吗？
Like this thing is designed with an inch of its life.
就像这个东西是用它的生命的一英寸来设计的。
I also thought it was funny that in 2005, like a wedding costing $400,000 is a really expensive wedding.
我还觉得很有趣的是，在 2005 年，一场花费 40 万美元的婚礼是一场非常昂贵的婚礼。
Like it's expensive now.
好像现在很贵
But like, that's a really expensive wedding.
但就像，那是一场非常昂贵的婚礼。
That is a really expensive wedding.
这真是一场昂贵的婚礼。
I know, we didn't, I don't know if we lived up to that in what we portrayed.
我知道，我们没有，我不知道我们是否达到了我们所描绘的那样。
We see like a couple of little tables.
我们看到有几张小桌子。
It looks like a Hilton ballroom.
它看起来像希尔顿宴会厅。
It doesn't look like, I think they got ripped off for that 400K for sure.
看起来，我认为他们肯定被骗了 400K。
Yeah, but Matt Boren is so, like he has the face of a like silent film comedian.
是的，但马特·博伦就是这样，就像他有一张无声电影喜剧演员的脸。
Oh yes, he's really funny.
哦，是的，他真的很有趣。
Like just an ability to just like be long suffering, You know, but not in a way where you feel like we got to go save him just in a way.
就像一种长期受苦的能力，你知道，但不是以一种让你觉得我们必须以某种方式拯救他的方式。
Like he's probably the only person who could just handle this, this energy.
好像他可能是唯一能够处理这种能量的人。
But he's kind of cocky in a way.
但他在某种程度上有点自大。
He's kind of like, I could get someone hotter than Claudia and your reaction.
他有点像，我可以找一个比克劳迪娅和你的反应更性感的人。
Another great 10 moment is when he starts laughing way too fast and way too hard at that.
另一个伟大的十个时刻是当他开始笑得太快、太用力时。
And that's the kind of like pull back from it.
这就是一种从其中撤退的感觉。
Like, well, that's crazy.
就像，嗯，这太疯狂了。
You shouldn't break up with your glottie.
你不应该和你的小家伙分手。
That was a great moment.
那是一个伟大的时刻。
Yeah, the scene where where Marshall and where they go to stage the intervention is very good.
是的，马歇尔和他们去现场干预的场景非常好。
I love that whole sequence.
我喜欢整个序列。
There's so many funny moments in that and Marshall ending up saying you should you should break up with her and then saying the sort of great reason why like what the stakes are of getting married.
其中有很多有趣的时刻，马歇尔最后说你应该和她分手，然后又说了一些重要的理由，比如结婚的风险是什么。
I thought that was really I love Jason played that I love and I love Ted's Dude, like, I stole that shout out to my Kentin College roommate, Matt Olens, I stole that from him.
我想这真的是我爱杰森演奏的，我爱我爱的，我爱泰德的家伙，就像，我偷了我向我的肯丁大学室友马特·奥伦斯喊的那句话，我从他那里偷了那句话。
He would do that all day.
他会整天这样做。
Dude, like, why are you saying that?
老兄，你为什么这么说？
So I kind of took that from him.
所以我从他那里继承了这一点。
You know, it was a dated moment too, if I may say so.
你知道，如果我可以这么说的话，这也是一个过时的时刻。
I think they're listening to great things about being single.
我认为他们正在聆听有关单身的美好事物。
I know exactly what you're going to say.
我完全知道你要说什么。
Having single when he's like, having porn.
当他喜欢看色情片时，他却单身。
No, he said owning porn.
不，他说拥有色情片。
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
Sorry.
对不起。
It's owning porn.
它拥有色情内容。
And I was like, how quaint, how quaint, how quaint is it?
我当时想，多么古怪，多么古怪，多么古怪？
You could only pour in one day.
你只能倒一天。
Where people owned their little, a little hand-picked curated up one stash.
人们拥有自己的一小部分，精心挑选的一小部分藏品。
Yeah.
是的。
And that is the internet and modern life has gotten rid of that incredibly charming thing where guys have a bag of VHS tapes or something, or DVDs and- And you know what?
这就是互联网，现代生活已经摆脱了人们拥有一袋 VHS 磁带或其他东西，或 DVD 以及 - 你知道吗？
Sometimes there was so much the circuits got jammed.
有时，太多电路会被堵塞。
The circuits got jammed?
电路被卡住了？
I was like, this is this episode, the circuits got jammed.
我当时想，这就是这一集，电路被堵塞了。
This is us calling back that in the limo, they say the circuits got jammed a hundred times about cell phone calls and it makes it sound like we don't know how cell phones work.
这是我们在豪华轿车里回电，他们说手机通话电路被堵塞了一百次，这听起来好像我们不知道手机是如何工作的。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
But I thought that was this week's of like owning porn.
但我认为这周就像拥有色情片一样。
Owning porn, yeah.
拥有色情片，是的。
There's not a lot, it's shocking though, how few references date the show.
虽然数量不多，但令人震惊的是，很少有参考文献注明​​该剧的日期。
Like there's a couple that I think are actually quite charming.
就像有一对我认为实际上非常迷人的情侣。
They jump out when they do.
当他们这样做时，他们就会跳出来。
They jump out and it's good.
他们跳出来，这很好。
You know what I loved?
你知道我爱什么吗？
I loved the fast forwarding sequence of the argument.
我喜欢争论的快进顺序。
Wasn't that with Stuart and Claudia were breaking up?
那不是斯图尔特和克劳迪娅要分手了吗？
Yeah, I love that.
是的，我喜欢那个。
We had to write a whole big, long argument for them.
我们必须为他们写一整篇又大又长的论证。
Those were separate script pages that they sort of had to do.
这些是他们必须做的单独的脚本页面。
And we said, it's not to be perfect on this, but they needed something that would take that long.
我们说，这并不是完美的，但他们需要一些需要那么长时间的东西。
We're literally fast forwarding through what they're really saying.
我们实际上是在快进地了解他们真正所说的内容。
That would have been great too.
那也太好了。
I should sometimes go back to the scripts before we do these podcasts clearly, because I've not done my homework.
有时我应该在我们清楚地制作这些播客之前回到脚本，因为我还没有完成我的作业。
It would be very cool if I had that and could just read what they're really saying.
如果我有这个并且可以读懂他们真正在说什么，那就太酷了。
But I don't, but they had a whole script.
但我不知道，但他们有完整的剧本。
but it was also cool.
但这也很酷。
It's a great storytelling thing because when you have like an argument that ends in a breakup, those are hours long, you know?
这是一个很棒的讲故事的事情，因为当你因为一场争吵而以分手告终时，那会持续几个小时，你知道吗？
Hours and hours.
几个小时又几个小时。
And you literally, you remember three sentences from them.
从字面上看，你记得他们的三句话。
You remember like the wounding lines or the ones that you're like, oh, we're not coming back from this.
你记得那些伤人的线条或者你喜欢的那些，哦，我们不会从这件事中回来。
Like this is really not.
这样的还真不是。
Yeah, we have crossed the Rubicon.
是的，我们已经越过了卢比孔河。
There's no putting this on that again.
没有办法再把这个放在那个上面了。
I love the moment where you stop and she just goes, end your mother.
我喜欢你停下来而她就走的那一刻，结束你的母亲。
I mean, you start fast-forwarding and that was my favorite moment of that.
我的意思是，你开始快进，这是我最喜欢的时刻。
They played that so great.
他们打得太棒了。
I wonder how long that went on for in real life.
我想知道这种情况在现实生活中持续了多久。
I'm gonna say it was hours.
我想说的是几个小时。
Yeah.
是的。
And then she goes and finally her best friend in the world.
然后她走了，最后成了她世界上最好的朋友。
It was also fun the way Virginia played Claudia was so, like, I mean, you know, when I think it's like Barney, like when you see it from the outside, you're like, why would these people be friends with it?
弗吉尼亚扮演克劳迪娅的方式也很有趣，就像，我的意思是，你知道，当我认为它像巴尼时，就像当你从外面看到它时，你会想，为什么这些人会和它成为朋友？
But when you have that much history and you know them from the inside, you know.
但当你有那么多历史并且从内部了解它们时，你就知道了。
But I liked how every time he had to call her, it was, he was justifiably scared, you know, like, yeah.
但我喜欢每次他不得不打电话给她时，他都有理由害怕，你知道，就像，是的。
She was in a scary state for sure, but again, but she played it with a humanity.
她确实处于一种可怕的状态，但她再次以人性的方式表演。
I liked it.
我喜欢它。
But again, the actresses have so much credit, Virginia.
但同样，女演员们有如此多的功劳，弗吉尼亚。
Having now gotten married and understanding the stakes involved in a wedding, the how much planning goes into a wedding, and for just like someone on the riff to call and be like, hey, cool, if I bring a date, It's like, it's maddening, you know?
现在已经结婚了，了解了婚礼所涉及的利害关系，婚礼需要进行多少规划，就像有人打电话说，嘿，酷，如果我带一个约会对象，这就像，这很令人抓狂，你知道吗？
Oh yeah.
哦，是的。
So I'm kind of like, I'm emotionally with Ted, but logistically, I'm like, yeah, Claudia had every right to scream at him.
所以我觉得，我在情感上对特德很支持，但从逻辑上讲，我想，是的，克劳迪娅完全有权利对他尖叫。
Like there's no.
就像没有一样。
Claudia is so justified.
克劳迪娅说的很有道理。
Ted is wrong, Ted is in the wrong for most of this episode.
泰德错了，泰德在这一集的大部分时间里都是错的。
And she comes across crazy, but she has a point, which is what makes it good.
她看起来很疯狂，但她有道理，这就是它的优点。
And Stewart is so great.
斯图尔特太棒了。
He just so haplessly walks into this, the drama he doesn't care about who's coming to the wedding and she really does.
他只是如此不幸地走进了这出戏，他并不关心谁会来参加婚礼，而她真的很关心。
and yeah, it's a great payoff when Robin doesn't even show up.
是的，当罗宾甚至没有出现时，这是一个巨大的回报。
And I love how Virginia played that moment too, where she's relaxed in that moment.
我也喜欢弗吉尼亚那一刻的表现，她在那一刻很放松。
They're married, they're at the party.
他们结婚了，他们正在参加聚会。
She's had a couple drinks.
她已经喝了几杯了。
And she's like able to laugh about it the way that when you look, it's true, right?
她就像能够笑起来，当你看起来时，这是真的，对吧？
You look back in your wedding and you go, ah, right, it was just, essentially it's just a party, right?
当你回顾你的婚礼时，你会发现，啊，对了，这只是，本质上只是一个派对，对吧？
It's like once you've done it, you sort of like changes immediately.
就像一旦你完成了某件事，你就喜欢立即改变。
My friend is getting married this summer in Paris.
我的朋友今年夏天要在巴黎结婚。
And he asked for my kind of hard earned wisdom around weddings.
他向我询问有关婚礼的来之不易的智慧。
And I said, weddings are the dress rehearsal is the performance.
我说，婚礼就是彩排就是表演。
Like you do not really get to rehearse, like the rehearsal, like that's not a rehearsal.
就像你没有真正排练一样，就像排练一样，就像那不是排练一样。
Like so much goes on that is, you know, there's going to be the things in the speeches that are, that kind of wound you a little bit, you know, like my friend, a friend of mine told me he at his wedding that I was at, there was a table in the back that was some really good friends and they were just talking so loud.
就像发生了很多事情一样，你知道，演讲中会有一些事情，会让你有点受伤，你知道，就像我的朋友，我的一个朋友告诉我，他在我参加的婚礼上，后面有一张桌子，里面有一些非常好的朋友，他们只是大声说话。
And he was so upset by it, but then he was told later the speaker that was by their table was kind of blown out and it was outside so they couldn't hear anything.
他对此感到非常沮丧，但后来他被告知，他们桌子旁边的扬声器有点被吹坏了，而且它在外面，所以他们听不到任何声音。
So they were like kind of detached from the whole thing and I just tried to say to him like, it's gonna be chaos, a lot is gonna go wrong, but the wrongness is part of the rightness.
所以他们有点脱离了整个事情，我只是试着对他说，这会很混乱，很多事情都会出错，但错误是正确的一部分。
Like you just have to bless the whole thing.
就像你只需要祝福整件事。
A wedding is chaos, and it's almost like marriage, like you just bless it all because it's all, it's never gonna, again, like with Ted, it's never gonna go according to your specifications, but it's gonna unfold the way it's gonna unfold and you gotta be okay with that.
婚礼是混乱的，它几乎就像婚姻一样，就像你只是祝福这一切，因为这一切，它永远不会再像泰德那样，它永远不会按照你的要求进行，但它会按照它要展开的方式展开，你必须接受这一点。
Yeah, yeah, and yeah, it's funny.
是啊，是啊，是啊，这很有趣。
The whole thing, I mean, this whole episode is yet another like exploration of plans and meeting reality, right, from all ends.
整件事，我的意思是，这整集又是一次对计划的探索和对现实的满足，对吧，从各个方面。
And the idea that Ted essentially sets off these dominoes that lead to the couple breaking up, because he's trying to will this plan into being.
泰德的想法本质上引发了这些导致这对夫妇分手的多米诺骨牌，因为他试图让这个计划成为现实。
It's yet again, Ted's kind of hubris, right?
特德又有点傲慢了，对吧？
If we're talking like basic Greek mythology story structure, like he flies too close to the sun by promising Ram in the slot.
如果我们谈论的是基本的希腊神话故事结构，就像他通过承诺拉姆在插槽中飞得离太阳太近一样。
And he is sorely punished.
并且他受到了严厉的惩罚。
And he really brings other people down with him when he comes crashing down.
当他崩溃的时候，他真的会带动其他人一起崩溃。
And you so understand you are rooting for Ted.
你知道你支持特德。
You know he's wrong.
你知道他错了。
If you're the couple getting married, he's wrong.
如果你们是结婚的情侣，他就错了。
But you're so rooting for Ted.
但你非常支持特德。
And you believe right when you first watched this episode, maybe you do think he checked that box, right?
当你第一次观看这一集时，你相信，也许你确实认为他勾选了那个框，对吗？
We know he didn't because we know how the episode ends, but when you're first watching it, it's pretty convincing that he does, right?
我们知道他没有这样做，因为我们知道这一集的结局，但当你第一次观看时，你会发现他确实这样做了，对吗？
The episode opens with him.
这一集以他开始。
It seems you almost feel like you saw him check the box.
看起来你几乎感觉就像看到他勾选了复选框。
Of course, we don't see which box he checks conveniently, but you feel like you see it and you work off that premise the whole time.
当然，我们看不到他方便地勾选了哪个框，但你感觉你看到了它，并且你一直在这个前提下工作。
And then it was, I'm reminded of it was a real reveal that he didn't, and Barney is basically, I love another great Neil moment in that episode.
然后，我想起这是一个真正的揭露，但他没有，巴尼基本上，我喜欢那一集里尼尔的另一个伟大时刻。
You know, so funny, his little Barney voice when he does a little Barney in the back of Ted's head.
你知道，当他在泰德脑后模仿巴尼的声音时，他的小巴尼声音太有趣了。
And I love that he's done this so many times and Marshall and Ted know exactly what it is.
我喜欢他已经这样做了很多次，而且马歇尔和泰德确切地知道这是什么。
I love the shared history.
我喜欢共同的历史。
But it's Barney's right, Barney's right.
但巴尼是对的，巴尼是对的。
Ted, some part of yourself deep down does not actually think you're ready for all the shit you're claiming you're ready for.
特德，你内心深处的某些部分实际上并不认为你已经准备好应对你声称自己已经准备好的所有事情。
And he's right.
他是对的。
It's also nice that even though Ted almost breaks up this marriage and ruins a $400,000 wedding, he's not a villain.
还好的是，尽管泰德差点破坏了这段婚姻并毁掉了一场价值 40 万美元的婚礼，但他并不是一个恶棍。
Like, that's really good writing, because it's not, you know, it's not like I'm scheming or, you know, Ted's scheming or doing something devious.
就像，这真的是很好的写作，因为它不是，你知道，这不像我在阴谋，或者，你知道，特德在阴谋或做一些不正当的事情。
He's actually just trying to do the right thing.
他实际上只是想做正确的事。
He's trying to do the right thing by Robin.
他正在努力为罗宾做正确的事。
He wants everyone to have a good time at this wedding.
他希望每个人都能在这场婚礼上度过愉快的时光。
And I like that it's not a morality play.
我喜欢这不是一部道德剧。
It's like we screw things up, like the road to hell is paved with good intentions, like that's what it is, you know?
就像我们把事情搞砸了，就像通往地狱的路是用善意铺成的，就像事情就是这样，你知道吗？
Yeah, yeah, I really like that.
是的，是的，我真的很喜欢。
It's complicated.
情况很复杂。
No one's a purely the villain.
没有人是纯粹的恶棍。
It is a really well written episode.
这真是写得很好的一集。
Shout out to the writer, Courtney Kang, who wrote this one, who's been on the show with us to talk about an earlier episode.
向编剧考特尼·康（Courtney Kang）致敬，他是本剧的作者，她在节目中与我们一起谈论了之前的一集。
She'll be back for sure.
她肯定会回来的。
Great, yeah, it's a great one.
太棒了，是的，这真是太棒了。
And it's funny, it's the first, because drumroll please, in some ways, I think gets talked about more by the fans and maybe by ourselves too.
这很有趣，这是第一个，因为请鼓乐，在某些方面，我认为粉丝们甚至我们自己也会更多地谈论这一点。
Like, because that's, we meet Ashley Williams.
就像，因为那就是，我们遇到了阿什利·威廉姆斯。
There's so many very memorable things in that.
这里面有很多非常值得纪念的事情。
This episode's so important.
这一集太重要了
It really is an hour long story.
这确实是一个小时长的故事。
Well, there's no drum roll without this episode.
好吧，没有这一集就没有鼓声。
Like this tees it up perfectly.
就像这样完美地开球。
Yeah, this is the drum roll, T-drum roll if it, as it were.
是的，这就是鼓声，可以说是 T 鼓声。
And it's like, it, and it's really urgent.
就像，它，而且真的很紧急。
It feels like the stakes are incredibly high.
感觉赌注非常高。
I love when, I love when the stakes aren't bullshit.
我喜欢当赌注不是胡说八道的时候。
It's like, for a minute in this episode, that wedding's off.
在这一集里，有那么一分钟，婚礼就结束了。
I love it.
我喜欢它。
It's like, it's really like stressful to watch in a good way, because you're like, there's really, and you really are rooting, you know, we're 12 episodes in and rooting for Ted and Robin or what's gonna happen with these two.
就像，以好的方式观看真的很有压力，因为你会想，真的，你真的很支持，你知道，我们已经播了 12 集，支持泰德和罗宾，或者这两个人会发生什么。
And this is it really ramping back up.
这就是它真正的回升。
And the idea that Robin doesn't come, and Hetera's that moment of saying, it's just not easy.
当罗宾没有来的时候，赫特拉就说，这并不容易。
The universe isn't actually putting this into place for me and Robin.
宇宙实际上并没有为我和罗宾安排这一切。
Barney was right.
巴尼是对的。
I'm not ready for any of this.
我还没有准备好接受这一切。
And then the twist being that he ends up meeting this other super intense love interest, a huge part of his life-love story.
然后转折是，他最终遇到了另一个超级强烈的爱情兴趣，这是他一生爱情故事的重要组成部分。
He meets Ashley Williams in that moment at the end of the episode, which one of my favorite music usages of the show, that soul meets body by death cab when you're pushing it on Ashley across the wedding, the $400,000 crappy hotel ballroom, it seems to be in.
在这一集结尾的那一刻，他遇到了阿什利·威廉姆斯，这是我最喜欢的剧中音乐用法之一，当你推着阿什利穿过婚礼时，灵魂与死亡出租车相遇，那似乎是在价值 40 万美元的破烂酒店宴会厅里。
Cash bar.
现金吧。
But I love that moment.
但我喜欢那一刻。
And it's just interesting, because there's a lot of twists and turns there at the end.
这很有趣，因为最后有很多曲折。
I like that ramp where you actually does meet a very serious love interest in that moment.
我喜欢那个坡道，在那里你在那一刻确实遇到了一个非常认真的爱情兴趣。
He seems to be giving up upon it.
他似乎要放弃了。
And if Robin hadn't gotten called to the station None of that would have happened.
如果罗宾没有被叫到车站，这一切都不会发生。
And this old man, he musted me, fell in love with you.
而这个老人，他必须让我爱上你。
New York City.
纽约市。
And now commercials.
现在是广告。
End of commercials?
广告完结了？
Back to show.
返回展示。
I also think there's something about the age, that kind of tender age of like 27, where it feels like the weddings are starting in earnest.
我还认为这与年龄有关，27 岁左右的年纪，感觉婚礼正在认真开始。
You know what I mean, especially in like New York, people get married a little later, like, there's something about that time where are you, do you have a plus one or don't you?
你知道我的意思，尤其是在纽约这样的地方，人们结婚的时间会晚一些，比如，那个时候你在哪里，你有加一吗？
Like, it's, it is, it is an existential issue.
就像，这是，这是，这是一个存在问题。
You know, like, do I, do I keep myself available in a wedding?
你知道，我会在婚礼上保持自己的状态吗？
Because people meet at weddings is one of the places where people meet and really, and it's such a romance is in the air and it's, it's hopeful and optimistic.
因为婚礼是人们见面的地方之一，空气中弥漫着浪漫的气息，充满希望和乐观。
And I think that, you know, that time, there's like a decade in your life where you're just going to a lot of of weddings.
我认为，你知道，那个时候，你生命中大约有十年的时间你会去参加很多婚礼。
And, and you know, when you go to them alone, it's, it's just a little trick.
而且，你知道，当你单独去找他们时，这只是一个小把戏。
I mean, I, some people prefer going to them alone and other people would rather have someone on their arm and, but they're, but they're provocative, right?
我的意思是，我，有些人喜欢单独去，而另一些人则宁愿有人在他们的手臂上，但他们是，但他们是挑衅性的，对吗？
Like they're, they're a little bit like, am I, is this ever going to happen to me or form it?
就像他们一样，他们有点像，我，这会发生在我身上吗？
You know, it's stir shit up for sure.
你知道，这肯定会引起轰动。
And I think that's why people get a little too drunk at weddings, like say the wrong thing at weddings, like it's a, yep, they're provocative times.
我认为这就是为什么人们在婚礼上喝醉了，比如在婚礼上说错话，就像这是一个，是的，这是一个挑衅的时刻。
There's big feelings.
有很大的感触。
This is what I say to my children.
这就是我对我的孩子们说的话。
There's big, you're having big feelings.
事情很大，你有很大的感受。
There's big feelings at weddings, right?
婚礼上有很大的感情，对吧？
They're just, the stakes are really high.
他们只是，赌注真的很高。
I'm proud of this episode, it's two-parter in a way, because it's again, like with, it's the same thing as with a holiday episode.
我为这一集感到自豪，从某种程度上来说，它是由两部分组成的，因为它又像假日集一样。
Don't do a holiday episode unless you have a really good idea, a really good take on a holiday episode or else just don't do the holiday.
除非你有一个非常好的主意，一个非常好的假日集，否则不要制作假日集，否则就不要制作假日集。
Doing a wedding episode, doing a comedic episode comedic movie about a wedding, you're very aware of the 7,000 years of wedding-related material that has preceded your little attempt to do something, set at a wedding.
制作婚礼剧集，制作一部关于婚礼的喜剧片喜剧电影，你会非常清楚 7000 年来与婚礼相关的材料，这些材料在你尝试做一些以婚礼为背景的事情之前就已经存在了。
And I like this dilemma so much, but I don't feel like I've seen this specific dilemma of like the plus one idea and the sort of symposium on, did I check this box and what's gonna happen?
我非常喜欢这种困境，但我不觉得我见过这种具体的困境，比如加一的想法和那种研讨会，我是否勾选了这个框，会发生什么？
And then I really like the ending sort of has this two or three twists all at once.
然后我真的很喜欢结局同时有两三个转折。
He didn't check the box.
他没有勾选这个框。
Maybe he's saying he should let go of Robin.
也许他是在说他应该放开罗宾。
He doesn't want to be, he wants to be single.
他不想单身，他想单身。
He looks across the room and literally sees an expert and he's going to fall in love with in that moment.
他环视房间，真的看到了一位专家，在那一刻他就会爱上他。
I love that in the last like 30 seconds of this episode, a lot happens.
我喜欢这一集的最后 30 秒，发生了很多事情。
Yeah.
是的。
There's that thing.
有那个东西。
It's a little bit of a new age cliche, but it's like something like the universe only gives you three answers to your prayers or requests.
这有点新时代的陈词滥调，但这就像宇宙只为你的祈祷或请求提供三个答案。
One is yes, another one is not yet.
一个是肯定的，另一个还没有。
And the third one is I have something better in mind.
第三个是我有更好的想法。
you, right?
你，对吗？
And Ted gets a, at least in this, you know, two-parter, he gets a, I have something better in mind for you right now, you know?
特德得到了，至少在这件事上，你知道，两人合作，他得到了，我现在有更好的想法给你，你知道吗？
He gets both not yet and I have something better in mind.
他还没有得到，而我心里有更好的想法。
He does, I love that.
他确实这么做了，我喜欢这样。
It's kind of like, it's a, it is a really fresh take on weddings and, you know, you could almost see the themes and stuff of this being expanded into a feature, like it would be a great kind of feature film about a wedding, right?
这有点像，这是对婚礼的一种非常新鲜的诠释，你知道，你几乎可以看到它的主题和内容被扩展成一个故事片，就像这将是一部很棒的关于婚礼的故事片，对吧？
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
Well, sometimes the answer of if you're afraid, how do we do a good wedding episode?
好吧，有时候，如果你害怕的话，答案是，我们怎样才能拍出一场精彩的婚礼呢？
Or how do you do a good New Year's Eve episode?
或者如何制作精彩的除夕夜剧集？
In both that episode and this one, which are back-to-back in the running order of season one, you never see the New Year's Eve party, and you basically don't see the wedding, right?
在这一集和这一集中，按照第一季的播放顺序，你从来没有看到除夕晚会，你基本上也没有看到婚礼，对吧？
There's no wedding.
没有婚礼。
You skip over the wedding, you're like, we don't become a cliche comedy take on weddings because you don't even see it.
你跳过婚礼，你会想，我们不会成为婚礼上的陈词滥调喜剧，因为你甚至没有看到它。
It's all about the run up to the wedding, and then the next episode basically jumps way into the past the wedding.
这一切都是关于婚礼的筹备，然后下一集基本上跳到婚礼过去。
It's the Rosenkrantz and Guildenstern, right?
这是罗森克兰茨和吉尔登斯特恩，对吧？
It is.
这是。
It's way different.
这是完全不同的。
Yeah, you follow the side characters.
是的，你跟着配角。
It's also, I don't know if you, we might have discussed this, but did you read the Mark Harris' Mike Nichols biography?
而且，我不知道你是否，我们可能已经讨论过这个问题，但是你读过马克·哈里斯的迈克·尼科尔斯传记了吗？
No, I don't know, not read it yet.
不，我不知道，还没读过。
I keep hearing how good it is.
我一直听说它有多好。
If you're like, in showbiz, it's like, I think, essential reading.
如果你喜欢在演艺圈，我认为这就像是必读书。
It's just really, it's like juicy, but also edifying somehow, and he was such a fascinating character.
真的，这就像多汁的，但也有某种启发性，而且他是一个如此迷人的角色。
but one of his truisms about romantic comedies, he said, if you want to make a classic romantic comedy, they can't get together at the end.
但他关于浪漫喜剧的一条不言而喻的真理是，如果你想拍一部经典的浪漫喜剧，最后他们就不能在一起。
The graduate is kind of like this really discordant, weird ending.
毕业生有点像这样非常不和谐、奇怪的结局。
It's not like a big celebration.
这不像是一场盛大的庆祝活动。
It's like, what have we done?
就像，我们做了什么？
That kind of look as they go on that bus towards an uncertain future.
当他们乘坐公共汽车前往不确定的未来时，他们的表情就是这样。
And I think that, You know, how I make your mother like both fulfills, it gives you everything you want, and it's constantly pulling your rug out from under you at the same time.
我认为，你知道，我如何让你的母亲喜欢这两种满足，它给了你想要的一切，同时它不断地把你的地毯从你身下拉出来。
Yeah.
是的。
And when Harry Metzali, there's that feeling at the end of when Harry Metzali, but it's still a journey, right?
当 Harry Metzali 时，在 Harry Metzali 结束时会有那种感觉，但这仍然是一个旅程，对吧？
It just ends with the two of them, and she's sort of like going on her long run at the end, as they're just sitting there, doing their little couple, sort of like talk to the camera thing.
故事就以他们两个结束了，她有点像在最后进行长跑，因为他们只是坐在那里，做着他们的小情侣，有点像对着镜头说话。
And it's true.
这是真的。
It's like, we all love a happy ending and a warm wrapped up ending, but it's true, they're really all timers.
就像，我们都喜欢幸福的结局和温暖的结局，但这是真的，他们真的都是定时器。
There's always something a little, there's a little, the edges aren't always sanded down at the end, because that's a great observation of my medicals.
总是有一点，有一点，最后边缘并不总是被打磨掉，因为这是对我的医疗的一个很好的观察。
And if you're, if you're an acute observer of life, very rarely are things symmetrical, perfect.
如果你是一个敏锐的生活观察者，那么对称、完美的事物就很少见。
Like, you kind of have to bless the, what's the, that Japanese thing, Wabi Sabi?
就像，你必须祝福日本的侘寂是什么？
Do you know what that is?
你知道那是什么吗？
like Japanese artists will put an intentional flaw in their piece and it's like a wink from the artist that says, I'm an artist, I'm an imperfect being and also like, I acknowledge that there is nothing perfect.
就像日本艺术家会在他们的作品中故意添加一个缺陷，就像艺术家眨眼说，我是一名艺术家，我是一个不完美的人，而且我承认没有什么是完美的。
So we should just dispense with that fiction right away.
所以我们应该立即放弃这种虚构。
Yes, that's great.
是的，那太好了。
Yeah, that's great.
Yeah.
是的。
I think it's the same ideas as doing an episode about a wedding and not showing a wedding or doing episode by New Year's Eve.
我认为这与制作有关婚礼的剧集而不展示婚礼或在除夕夜制作剧集的想法相同。
It's like, so much of life happens not at the thing you think it's about.
就像，生活中的很多事情都不是按照你想象的那样发生的。
It happens around the thing.
它发生在事情周围。
And before the thing and after the thing, it's almost a testament to there's no endings.
而事情之前和事情之后，这几乎证明了没有结局。
There's one, death is the one big ending.
有一个，死亡是最大的结局。
Well, it's also the thing of like, we're, and I think part of the challenge of life is to not be the main character all the time.
嗯，这也是这样的事情，我们，我认为生活挑战的一部分就是不要一直成为主角。
That's why having children is like healthy for the soul and sometimes hard on the ego, because you really have to dethrone yourself.
这就是为什么生孩子对灵魂来说是健康的，但有时对自我来说却是困难的，因为你真的必须推翻自己。
But when you're at a wedding, you are the main character of your story of the night, but you're not the main character of that evening because that's the bride and groom, right?
但是当你参加婚礼时，你是当晚故事的主角，但你不是那天晚上的主角，因为那是新娘和新郎，对吧？
So you're like 10 rows back, and you're having, you know, maybe an argument with your wife or girlfriend, whatever, like, but that's your experience of the wedding is from that perspective.
所以你大概在后面 10 排，你知道，你可能会和你的妻子或女朋友发生争吵，无论如何，但这就是你从这个角度经历的婚礼。
That's the story of your wedding.
这就是你的婚礼的故事。
And the bride and groom are kind of like, fogging off in the distance.
新娘和新郎有点像，在远处雾气缭绕。
Totally, it's totally Rosingrad's ago that's starting to wait and figure it out.
总而言之，这完全是罗辛格勒之前的事了，人们开始等待并找出答案。
It's like that's what it's like to go to a what?
就好像去什么地方一样？
You're not the main characters.
你不是主角。
You are off, but there, you can have all this drama going on off on your little table at table 10.
你已经离开了，但在那里，你可以在 10 号桌的小桌子上上演所有这些戏剧性的事情。
There's a whole other drama happening.
还有另外一出戏剧正在发生。
Yeah, what was, I just had one other question, to Marshall.
是的，什么是，我只是还有一个问题要问马歇尔。
Interpreting your notes.
解释你的笔记。
When did Ted say to Marshall, do you think she's into me?
特德什么时候对马歇尔说，你认为她喜欢我吗？
Like, it was kind of like a- I love that moment.
就像，有点像——我喜欢那一刻。
It was like in the middle of a heated thing and then- Yeah.
就像是在一个激烈的事情中间然后——是的。
And then he drops it all like, do you think, you know, He's so ready to drop plans to drop.
然后他就放弃了一切，你认为，你知道吗，他已经准备好放弃计划了。
Like he helped his entire energy changes when the possibility that.
就像他帮助他整个能量发生变化时的可能性那样。
Yeah, and you know what?
是的，你知道吗？
It's a callback to the limo.
这是对豪华轿车的回调。
Remember it's a callback to the limo when Ted and his date are up and up through the sunroof of the limo.
请记住，当泰德和他的约会对象从豪华轿车的天窗上爬出来时，这是对豪华轿车的回调。
It's like, really?
真的是这样吗？
Do you, do you, do you, do you, do you do me?
你，你，你，你，你对我吗？
It's very, it's like two of those in two episodes.
这非常，就像两集中的两个。
And yeah, very funny the way you play that.
是的，你的演奏方式非常有趣。
That was another good one, Josh.
那又是一件好事，乔什。
See, we're gonna compliment you.
瞧，我们要夸奖你。
I'm gonna give some notes on the writing when I'm gonna give you compliments.
当我要给你赞美的时候，我会在写作上做一些笔记。
The other writing note I have is like, for this whole two-parter, no one should ever answer the phone.
我的另一封信是，对于这整个两人来说，任何人都不应该接电话。
There's always like, ah, we've solved the problem.
总是有这样的感觉，啊，我们已经解决了问题。
Ring, ring, and then the phone, and it's like, Robin gets called to go do the newscast.
铃声响起，铃声响起，然后是电话，罗宾接到电话去做新闻广播。
I said, it was watching me in the back, I said, no one should ever answer the phone on TV.
我说，它在后面看着我，我说，任何人都不应该在电视上接电话。
The phone's always just don't answer the fucking phone.
电话总是不接。
But those are the Deus Ex Machina, those are the universe.
但那些是杀出重围，那些是宇宙。
That's how the universe like disrupts everyone's plan.
宇宙就是这样打乱每个人的计划的。
It's the universe calling, it's the universe calling, for sure.
这是宇宙的召唤，这是宇宙的召唤，当然。
I wanna say one thing just about the overall writing instructor of this is that if you think of this episode, sort of as a twist, it's a bit of a twist episode, right, because we really feel like this is about the back and forth of Ted and Robin, and then you give us this wonderful twist.
我想说关于这集整体写作指导的一件事是，如果你认为这一集有点转折，那就是有点转折，对吧，因为我们真的觉得这是关于泰德和罗宾的来回，然后你给了我们这个美妙的转折。
And I think a lot about how successful twist movies, the best ones are ones that work not quite without the twist, but that the second time around, it's not just about the twist.
我想了很多关于如何成功的扭曲电影，最好的电影是那些没有扭曲就行不通的电影，但第二次，它不仅仅是关于扭曲的。
It's still great storytelling until then.
在那之前它仍然是很棒的故事。
And I feel like that's what you have here.
我觉得这就是你们这里所拥有的。
You have this great Ted and Robin confusion, wedding episode, oh, and there's this twist.
你有泰德和罗宾的巨大困惑，婚礼情节，哦，还有这个转折。
But then as from everything you guys are talking about, it's completely part of the fabric of the episode, the idea that this is leading somewhere for him.
但从你们谈论的一切来看，这完全是这一集结构的一部分，这个想法将引导他走向某个地方。
A lot of perfect things had to happen or not happen to get to, I can see this girl across the room and pursue it.
很多完美的事情必须发生或不会发生，我可以看到房间另一边的这个女孩并追求它。
And it just really worked both ways for me.
这对我来说确实是双向的。
Yeah.
是的。
That's nice to hear.
很高兴听到这个消息。
I really liked that on second watching, too, and realizing that this spins you in a whole new part of the season.
我在第二次观看时也非常喜欢这一点，并意识到这会让你进入本季的全新部分。
That's great.
那太棒了。
You think we're going back to Ted and Robin, and maybe people watching you be like, oh, that's pretty soon to go back, right?
你认为我们会回到泰德和罗宾，也许人们看着你会说，哦，很快就会回去，对吧？
I thought we put that to bed, and now they're all friends.
我以为我们已经解决了，现在他们都是朋友了。
It's already coming back in the dead middle of the season.
它已经在赛季中期回归了。
It was complete mislead.
这完全是误导。
We were actually not gonna come back to them until the end of season one.
实际上，直到第一季结束我们才会回到他们身边。
And I like that this spins it out into something completely unforeseen.
我喜欢这将它变成完全不可预见的事情。
And yeah, it's the universe calling.
是的，这是宇宙的召唤。
Alright, let's, uh, Josh, we have a very special, uh, portion of our show.
好吧，让我们，呃，乔什，我们的节目有一个非常特别的，呃，部分。
Would you like to introduce it?
您愿意介绍一下吗？
Oh, sure.
哦，当然。
Yeah, this is very exciting.
是的，这非常令人兴奋。
This is, uh, a section we like to call questions and observations from a clinical psychologist who's never seen how I met your mother and also happens to be married to Josh.
这是，呃，我们喜欢将这一部分称为临床心理学家的问题和观察，他从未见过我是如何认识你母亲的，而且碰巧与乔什结婚了。
So I was most taken by that moment when Ted came to the conclusion based on Marshall's advice that love shouldn't be that hard, should be simple and easy.
所以，当泰德根据马歇尔的建议得出结论时，我最感动的那一刻是：爱不应该那么困难，应该简单而容易。
And I'm so often working with patients around this concept, what should it feel like when you found the person you're meant to be with?
我经常围绕这个概念与患者一起工作，当你找到你注定要在一起的人时，你会感觉如何？
What parts should feel easy?
哪些部分应该感觉轻松？
And when is it okay and actually normal for it to feel quite hard?
什么时候感觉很困难才是正常的？
Because, you know, in truth, long-term love does indeed take work.
因为，你知道，事实上，长久的爱情确实需要努力。
And how do you know when it's too hard?
你怎么知道什么时候太难了？
So these are very big questions, but I am wondering where you stand here, you know, more specifically, what is easy and what's the kind of hard that just is the price of admission for a long-term relationship?
所以这些都是非常大的问题，但我想知道你站在哪里，更具体地说，什么是容易的，什么是困难的，这就是建立长期关系的代价？
That's a good one.
这是一件好事。
I found myself thinking about it too, Jernana.
我发现自己也在思考这个问题，Jernana。
When you're watching, when Marshall gives that speech, I hadn't watched that speech in a long time and it felt very young to me.
当你观看马歇尔发表演讲时，我已经很长时间没有看过那个演讲了，对我来说感觉很年轻。
Marshall is the older, wiser guy in that moment because he's engaged and he's been with Lilly since he's 18 years old from freshman year of of college.
马歇尔在那一刻是一个更年长、更聪明的人，因为他已经订婚了，而且从他 18 岁大学一年级起就一直和莉莉在一起。
And yet, looking back at it now, it's like, that is kind of a young take in a way, because it's not easy, right?
然而，现在回想起来，这在某种程度上是一种年轻的想法，因为这并不容易，对吧？
It's not.
它不是。
It's like you have to work at it.
就好像你必须努力去做一样。
It's nothing is always effortless.
没有什么事情总是不费吹灰之力的。
I think he was talking about, there has to be some spirit of effortlessness.
我想他说的是，必须要有一些不费力气的精神。
There has to be some effortlessness to the decision to be with that person, right?
和那个人在一起的决定一定是毫不费力的，对吧？
That's how I took it.
我就是这么接受的。
It should be like, well, I have to breathe oxygen.
应该就像，嗯，我必须呼吸氧气。
That's not negotiable.
这是没有商量余地的。
It should kind of feel that right?
应该有这样的感觉吧？
Love should feel that way.
爱情就应该是这样的感觉。
It should feel worth, I guess it should be an effort, this decision, and then beyond that, you know, there's going to be hard stuff.
它应该让人感觉值得，我想这应该是一种努力，这个决定，然后除此之外，你知道，将会有困难的事情。
But the decision part should feel like it's natural to you.
但决策部分对你来说应该感觉很自然。
And I think that's how I viewed the speech this time.
我想这就是我对这次演讲的看法。
How did you feel that, Josh?
乔什，你感觉如何？
How did you interpret that?
你是如何解释的？
Yeah, I think that's right.
是的，我认为这是对的。
I mean, I think, especially in first season, Marshall and Lily do have a, they're, I mean, because they're, they're, especially in this first season, they're more, they are the parents, they're like Ted's parents, you know, they are, that really is a role that they play.
我的意思是，我认为，特别是在第一季，马歇尔和莉莉确实有一个，他们，我的意思是，因为他们，他们，特别是在第一季，他们更多，他们是父母，他们就像泰德的父母，你知道，他们是，这确实是他们扮演的角色。
And even Lily, this is a drum roll line, but she says, to Robin, like, happiness shouldn't be this hard.
即使是莉莉，这也是一句鼓声，但她说，对罗宾来说，幸福不应该这么难。
Doesn't she say something like that?
她不是说过这样的话吗？
She does.
她做到了。
Yeah.
是的。
Which is both great.
这两者都很棒。
And also, like a little bit condescending and a little, like not entirely true.
而且，有点居高临下，有点不完全正确。
Yeah.
是的。
I think some people struggle in their career very mightily, some people struggle in relationships.
我认为有些人在职业生涯中非常挣扎，有些人在人际关系中挣扎。
But I don't think that anything we do as humans, I don't think that anyone can inoculate themselves against struggle and hardship.
但我不认为我们作为人类所做的任何事情，我不认为任何人都能让自己免受斗争和困难的影响。
I think it's coming for all of us in various forms.
我认为它将以各种形式降临到我们所有人身上。
And I think when it comes to relationships, a friend of mine who's older than me, but very wise about relationships, he said, you know, the thing that makes us fall and love is this feeling of similarity.
我想当谈到人际关系时，我的一个朋友比我年长，但对人际关系非常明智，他说，你知道，让我们坠入爱河的就是这种相似的感觉。
Like, oh my God, we love the same bands and the same movies and we have the same taste and aesthetic and, you know, and we both love to talk about our feeling, like all these things that go check, check, check, check, check.
就像，天哪，我们喜欢同样的乐队和同样的电影，我们有同样的品味和审美，你知道，我们都喜欢谈论我们的感受，就像所有这些检查、检查、检查、检查、检查的事情。
Oh, don't we line up?
哦，我们不排队吗？
And that's, it's almost like nature's way to get you bonded, right?
这就是说，这几乎就像大自然让你们联系在一起的方式，对吧？
And then after you've been with a person for a while, these differences start announcing themselves.
当你和一个人在一起一段时间后，这些差异开始显现出来。
And then you have to navigate The the difference, you know, I don't think Jordy, I don't want to mind me saying this but like a central thing in our relationship is like She is a Google calendar planner in a way that would make your head spin like she'll go Hey, do you want to do so-and-so next Thursday at three and I'll go Okay, and I'll look down on my phone and I already I have a Google calendar invite.
然后你必须找出差异，你知道，我不认为乔迪，我不想介意我这么说，但就像我们关系中的一个核心事情一样，她是一名谷歌日历规划师，这会让你头晕，就像她会说嘿，你想下周四三点做某事吗，我会去好吧，我会低头看我的手机，我已经收到了谷歌日历邀请。
It's there down, it's just she leaned it into my phone.
它就在那里，只是她把它塞进了我的手机里。
And I have a thing where I don't know how I'm going to feel at Thursday on Thursday at three because I'm not thinking about Thursday at three, I'm thinking about today.
我有一件事，我不知道星期四下午三点我会有什么感觉，因为我考虑的不是星期四三点，而是今天。
That's future Josh's problem.
这是未来乔希的问题。
It's future Josh's problem, it's not my problem.
这是未来乔希的问题，不是我的问题。
And I think that, you know, I don't know if this is so gendered because I think there are men who are incredibly regimented and planning and list making and all those things.
我认为，你知道，我不知道这是否如此性别化，因为我认为有些男人非常有条理、有计划、列清单等等。
But I have had to yield and bend more towards, Like, I've really had to like get on top of the Google shared calendar, right?
但我不得不屈服并更多地倾向于，就像，我真的不得不喜欢掌握谷歌共享日历，对吧？
Like, like for the sake of my marriage, I've had to become much more of a planner.
就像，为了我的婚姻，我必须变得更像一个计划者。
And planning vacations is very hard because I'm like, I don't know how many of you, I don't know how I'll have a job then, you know, I'm talking about our marriage.
计划假期非常困难，因为我想，我不知道你们有多少人，我不知道如何找到工作，你知道，我正在谈论我们的婚姻。
I know.
我知道。
Did she walk in right as you began this page?
当你开始这一页时，她是正确走进来的吗？
So everyone, it's been a real navigation.
所以大家，这是一次真正的导航。
And it's also like, you know, she's had to bend and yield in certain ways towards, and I've had to bend and yield.
这也就像，你知道，她必须以某种方式屈服和屈服，而我也必须屈服和屈服。
but that's the kind of thing where, you know, that's like good struggle, like that's like good, you know, and it also I think part of the blessing and opportunity of a relationship is it dislodges you from your patterns or at least highlights them to be seen, which sometimes is you don't want them to be highlighted seem like, you know, but it ultimately makes you a more elastic kind of person, right?
但这就是那种事情，你知道，就像好的斗争，就像好的一样，你知道，而且我认为一段关系的祝福和机会的一部分是它使你摆脱你的模式或至少突出它们被看到，有时你不希望它们被突出显示，你知道，但它最终使你成为一个更有弹性的人，对吗？
And which I think is a net positive, right?
我认为这是一个净积极的结果，对吧？
It's a net positive.
这是一个净积极的结果。
You have to evolve, right?
你必须进化，对吗？
You can't get with someone and it's all a yes and you need to be challenged a little bit or else you'll never grow.
你无法与某人相处，一切都是肯定的，你需要接受一点挑战，否则你永远不会成长。
Even this episode, it's funny, the storyline, the little B, I wouldn't even call it a B, but a C or D story runner like is Lily and Marshall not agreeing on anything about this wedding.
即使是这一集，也很有趣，故事情节，小B，我什至不会称其为B，但像莉莉和马歇尔这样的C或D故事运行者对这场婚礼的任何事情都没有达成一致。
And again, to come back to the gender flip idea, Marshall wants this much sort of like, you know, Lily says, oh, you've been dreaming of, you know, Marshall's like, I'm dreaming about wedding ever since I was and she's like a little girl, you know what I mean?
再说一次，回到性别翻转的想法，马歇尔想要这样的感觉，你知道，莉莉说，哦，你一直梦想着，你知道，马歇尔就像，我从一开始就梦想着婚礼，她就像一个小女孩，你知道我的意思吗？
There's a little gender flip there.
那里有一点性别翻转。
Marshall wants this way more traditional sort of fruity wedding.
马歇尔想要这种更传统的果味婚礼。
And she clearly wants something a little less traditional out in the woods.
她显然想要在树林里做一些不那么传统的事情。
And like, this whole episode's storyline is them not agreeing on shit.
就像，整集的故事情节是他们在狗屎上没有达成一致。
And yet he's still his overall feeling that he says to Stewart is it should be effortless.
但他对斯图尔特说的总体感觉仍然是这应该毫不费力。
And I think he's talking about the decision to go through this thing called life with this other person, even as he's at the same time, not agreeing on any one thing with Stuart.
我认为他正在谈论与另一个人一起经历这件叫做生活的事情的决定，即使他同时不同意斯图尔特的任何一件事。
I mean, with Lilly, he's still able to say this to Stuart, and you see, when they finally got to the wedding, there's like this little moment where they agree on one thing about the wedding planning.
我的意思是，和莉莉一起，他仍然可以对斯图尔特说这些，你看，当他们最终参加婚礼时，他们在婚礼策划的一件事上达成了一致。
But that's not, that's not Marshall and Lilly being in lockstep, you know?
但事实并非如此，马歇尔和莉莉并没有步调一致，你知道吗？
Right, right.
对，对。
Also, though, I think in some ways, I don't think like in later seasons, like it doesn't It seemed like Lily Aldrin would want an outdoor way.
不过，我认为在某些方面，我不认为像后来的几季那样，莉莉·奥尔德林似乎想要一种户外的方式。
I know, we met a little bit of a little bit of a little like hippie for her.
我知道，我们遇到了有点像嬉皮士的她。
Like I don't know.
就像我不知道一样。
A little hippie.
有点嬉皮士。
Yeah.
是的。
Like I feel like Marshall would want like a Minnesota, like the high school football field in Minnesota or something.
我觉得马歇尔想要像明尼苏达州一样，像明尼苏达州的高中足球场之类的。
You could have flipped it there.
你可以把它翻到那里。
Yeah.
是的。
You could have flipped it.
你本可以把它翻转过来。
Yeah, it's true.
是的，这是真的。
We're still finding the characters.
我们仍在寻找角色。
The one thing we need for sure is that Lily's best friend is Claudia, that I'll stand by.
我们需要确定的一件事是莉莉最好的朋友是克劳迪娅，我会站在一边。
Alec, I couldn't help but notice you're wearing a really nice shirt today.
亚历克，我忍不住注意到你今天穿了一件非常漂亮的衬衫。
Do you want to talk us through that?
你想和我们谈谈吗？
Top bro.
顶一下兄弟
Yeah, top bro.
是啊，顶哥。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
Okay.
好的。
And then we know what's going on Instagram now with this whole thing.
然后我们就知道 Instagram 上现在发生了什么事。
This is this part of a new March here.
这是这里新三月的一部分。
This is our college style.
这就是我们大学的风格。
How we made your how what is the show called?
我们如何让您知道这个节目叫什么？
How we made your mother?
我们是如何造就你母亲的？
Yeah, that's what's called this shirt.
是的，这就是所谓的这件衬衫。
You're the producer of it.
你是它的制作人。
Yeah.
是的。
You work on the show because I was a good show.
你参加这个节目是因为我的节目很棒。
Um, I don't have the, I should know this because I am the producer, but I believe by the time you're hearing this, we have already been to Wesleyan University and, and, and, and done a little live show there, which will be in our feed.
嗯，我没有，我应该知道这一点，因为我是制片人，但我相信当你听到这个的时候，我们已经去过卫斯理大学了，并且，并且，在那里做了一些现场表演，这将出现在我们的动态中。
And we thought, okay, well, we're going to a college, like a college style shirt, uh, we've got another one that's just our logo, 10% of all the profits are going to, uh, how you make a difference are our, our campaign to support a congenital heart disease research.
我们想，好吧，好吧，我们要去一所大学，就像一件大学风格的衬衫，呃，我们还有另一件只是我们的标志，所有利润的 10% 将用于，呃，你如何做出改变是我们的，我们支持先天性心脏病研究的活动。
Very proud of that.
对此感到非常自豪。
And I'm just going to tell you this, I'm going to tell you that I'm going to, kids, I get to say that, kids, get to say the incredible story of how we met our friends at Amplifier who are partnering with us to get some legendary, how we made your mother merged you while raising money for congenital heart disease research.
我只是要告诉你们这个，我要告诉你们，我要告诉你们，孩子们，我要说的是，孩子们，我们要讲述一个令人难以置信的故事，我们如何在 Amplifier 遇到我们的朋友，他们与我们合作获得一些传奇人物，我们如何让你的母亲将你合并，同时为先天性心脏病研究筹集资金。
Amplifier is helping us to do something good by offering, premium fans, something great.
Amplifier 正在帮助我们做一些好事，为优质粉丝提供一些很棒的东西。
So if you are a business with big orders to fulfill, Amplifier is there to help growing consumer brands and influencers create a unique experience for their customers during the fulfillment process.
因此，如果您是一家需要履行大订单的企业，Amplifier 可以帮助成长中的消费品牌和影响者在履行过程中为其客户创造独特的体验。
The link to their site is in our show notes and if you name drop how we made your mother, you'll get special pricing for your emerging brands program.
他们网站的链接在我们的演出笔记中，如果您说出我们如何创造您的母亲，您将获得新兴品牌计划的特价。
If you want to get this merch, just go to howimajormother.com, click on store.
如果您想获得此商品，只需访问 howimajormother.com，点击商店即可。
You could also go to howyougetyourmerch.com and you'll go right to our Shopify location.
您还可以访问 howyougetyourmerch.com，然后您将直接转到我们的 Shopify 位置。
Alec, if we do any social media posts about the merch, which I assume we will, I think Hot Top Bro is a good.
Alec，如果我们在社交媒体上发布任何有关该商品的帖子（我想我们会的），我认为 Hot Top Bro 是一个很好的选择。
Hot Top Bro.
热顶兄弟。
It's fantastic.
太棒了。
Yeah.
是的。
It's going up.
它正在上升。
It's going to be up.
它会起来的。
It's going to be up before people hear this because we record this now.
在人们听到之前它就会响起，因为我们现在就录制了。
It comes out in four weeks, but there will have been just exactly that.
四个星期后就会出来，但确实会这样。
That's fantastic.
太棒了。
Awesome.
惊人的。
Yes.
是的。
And the reason for cause really close to my heart, close to it, it's the doctor who is the expert and in condition my son has and also works just with the larger pediatric congenital heart population doing research to help kids like that.
原因真的很接近我的心，很接近它，因为医生是专家，而且我儿子的病情也很严重，而且还与更大的儿科先天性心脏病患者一起进行研究，以帮助这样的孩子。
So yeah, thank you guys.
所以是的，谢谢你们。
Anyone anyone who buys this merch, you're supporting something really and truly amazing that's very, very close to my heart, my family starts to thank you.
任何购买这款商品的人，你们都在支持一些真正令人惊叹的东西，这非常非常贴近我的心，我的家人开始感谢你们。
And you become a walking ambassador for the show, so we're super grateful for that.
你成为了该剧的行走大使，所以我们对此非常感激。
Now, as tradition dictates, I'm going to read a wonderful letter that we received.
现在，按照传统规定，我将阅读我们收到的一封精彩的信。
Please write us letters, submit voice notes, maybe we'll read your letter on the air or or hear your voice at the start of an episode, but just tell us what, how I met your mother means to you or any other wonderful, how I met your mother related things you want to share with us.
请给我们写信，提交语音笔记，也许我们会在广播中读到您的信，或者在剧集开始时听到您的声音，但请告诉我们，我如何遇见你母亲对你意味着什么，或者任何其他与我如何遇见你母亲相关的精彩事情，你想与我们分享。
Go to how we made your mother dot com contact.
请参阅我们如何与您的母亲 .com 取得联系。
Is that right Alec and then everything should be pretty clear after that.
Alec 是这样吗？之后一切都应该很清楚了。
Okay.
好的。
So this is a wonderful letter we received from Emily.
这是我们从艾米丽那里收到的一封很棒的信。
It says, December 2008, I was at the hospital delivery unit at the start of what was to be an almost 48 hour labor.
上面说，2008 年 12 月，我在医院分娩室开始了近 48 小时的分娩。
My husband zipped out and returned with his laptop and season three of how I met your mother, which he'd quickly picked up at Best Buy.
我丈夫迅速出门，带着他的笔记本电脑和《我如何遇见你母亲》第三季回来了，他很快就在百思买买了这本书。
We'd been watching together since in season one, I'd been a Buffy fan and follow it, Alison Hannigan.
我们从第一季开始就一起看，我是《巴菲》的粉丝并一直追随它，艾莉森·汉尼根。
I'm sure we had already seen all of season three, but I remember us sitting on the hospital bed together waiting and waiting, and at least for a little while, pleasantly distracted with these great characters we do so well.
我确信我们已经看完了第三季的全部内容，但我记得我们一起坐在医院的病床上等啊等，至少有一段时间，我们愉快地被这些我们表现得如此出色的伟大角色所吸引。
We'd also moved from New York a few years prior and reveled in the nostalgia for evenings with friends at our favorite bar, even while we looked toward our future.
几年前，我们也从纽约搬到了这里，纵然在展望未来的同时，我们仍沉浸在与朋友们在我们最喜欢的酒吧共度夜晚的怀旧之情中。
I started re-watching this series this past January for the first time and came upon the new podcast on a subreddit.
去年一月，我第一次重新观看这个系列，并在 Reddit 子版块上发现了新的播客。
Such perfect timing.
如此完美的时机。
And imagine my delight as well to discover that I'd missed most of Season 8.
想象一下当我发现我错过了第八季的大部分内容时我有多高兴。
My second child was an infant then.
那时我的第二个孩子还是个婴儿。
It's also possible I did watch it, but just have no memory of it.
也有可能我确实看过，但只是不记得了。
So it's like a whole lost season for me, rebound.
所以这对我来说就像是一个失去的赛季，反弹。
Thank you for the show.
谢谢你的演出。
It has a ton of heart and its creativity knows no bounds.
它有大量的心血和无限的创造力。
I'm grateful to you all for putting this out in the world, even if I'm pretty sure it is behind my continued overuse of the word awesome.
我很感谢你们把这个公布于世，即使我很确定这是我继续过度使用“很棒”这个词的原因。
You did good.
你做得很好。
Be well.
祝你一切顺利。
Emily from Oberlin, Ohio.
艾米丽来自俄亥俄州欧柏林。
Thanks, Emily.
谢谢，艾米丽。
Thank you, Emily.
谢谢你，艾米丽。
That's fantastic.
太棒了。
I love when people have like these core memories that have been formed around how I met your mother.
我喜欢人们拥有这些围绕我如何遇见你母亲而形成的核心记忆。
Like we're our little show is part of the birth of her child and she remembers that.
就像我们的小节目是她孩子出生的一部分，她记得这一点。
And that's great.
那太好了。
In a very meta way, not to do spoilers, there is an episode of how I met your mother about distracting a pregnant woman who is in painful labor with storytelling, right?
为了不剧透，以一种非常元的方式，有一个关于我如何遇见你母亲的情节，是通过讲故事来分散一位正在痛苦分娩的孕妇的注意力，对吧？
There's an episode just spoilers, we are constantly trying to figure out whether we're doing spoilers of the show.
有一集只是剧透，我们一直在努力弄清楚我们是否在剧透。
But way later in the series, there is an episode where that's the idea of the episode, and now we're hearing how much mother fulfilled that role for her.
但在该系列的后期，有一集就是这一集的想法，现在我们听到母亲为她履行了多少角色。
So that's really cool.
所以这真的很酷。
I also think it's funny discovering like a lost treasure trove of how I met your mother episodes.
我还认为发现《我是如何遇见你母亲》的情节就像一个失落的宝库一样有趣。
But I'm not sure I might have seen this, but I had no memory of it.
但我不确定我是否见过这个，但我不记得了。
Think about it.
想一想。
You didn't even know what your notes on this episode meant that you wrote last night, Josh.
你甚至不知道你昨晚写的关于这一集的笔记意味着什么，乔什。
Now imagine it's basically a year of your life like that.
现在想象一下，这基本上就是你生命中的一年。
But it's funny because one thing that I ascribed to how I met your mother super fans is an intense memory of every episode.
但这很有趣，因为我将与你妈妈的超级粉丝见面的方式归因于对每一集的强烈记忆。
So it's really funny that the kind of mom brain would eradicate this It's the whole season in your head.
所以这真的很有趣，那种妈妈的大脑会根除你脑海中的整个季节。
Yes, happens to dads too, to be fair.
是的，公平地说，这也发生在爸爸身上。
Yeah.
是的。
Thank you, Emily.
谢谢你，艾米丽。
That's awesome.
太棒了。
We're so honored to have been a part of your labor.
我们很荣幸能成为你们工作的一部分。
It's a weird sentence, but we are.
这是一个奇怪的句子，但我们确实如此。
I am guilty.
我有罪。
Please equip me.
请装备我。
All sins are forgiven in New York City.
在纽约市，所有的罪孽都被宽恕。
How we made your mother is hosted an executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《我们如何造就你的母亲》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯担任执行制片人主持。
The show was produced by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
该节目由我 Alec Lev 制作，我们的联合制作人是 Doug Matica。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point of Blue Studios, and our digital content producer AKA Gen Z Master is Emily Blumber.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Point of Blue Studios 的 Alex Reeves，我们的数字内容制作人又名 Gen Z Master 是 Emily Blumber。
Artwork by John Morrow.
约翰·莫罗的艺术作品。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在 Apple 播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论该节目。
It really does help the show.
对节目确实有帮助。
Our theme song is NYC by our own Josh Radner, with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是我们自己的 Josh Radner 创作的《NYC》，其他音乐由 Craig Thomas 和 Andrew Majuski 创作。
Special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢洛拉·肯尼迪和埃利奥特·康纳斯。
Visit HowWeMajorMother.com to sign up for our sub-stack mailing list and for links to our social media.
请访问 HowWeMajorMother.com 注册我们的子堆栈邮件列表以及我们社交媒体的链接。
You can also click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
您还可以单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Want some merch?
想要一些商品吗？
Click on the store link or go to HowYouGetYourMerch.com.
单击商店链接或访问 HowYouGetYourMerch.com。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's Muse Letters on Substack, order Craig Thomas' debut novel at CraigThomasRider.com slash novel, and you could subscribe to my Dead Father's Society, also on Substack.
在 Substack 上订阅乔什·拉德纳 (Josh Radner) 的《Muse Letters》，在 CraigThomasRider.com 斜杠小说上订购克雷格·托马斯 (Craig Thomas) 的处女作，你还可以在 Substack 上订阅我的《死去父亲的协会》(Dead Father's Society)。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for congenital heart disease research.
要了解您如何做出改变，这显示了正在进行的为先天性心脏病研究筹集资金的活动。
Check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
查看我们网站顶部的“Make a Difference”选项卡。
This episode was made possible by the support of Backyard Ventures.
这一集是在 Backyard Ventures 的支持下才得以实现的。
People will, in fact, dance.
事实上，人们会跳舞。
A real question, it just hit me, am I in love with you?
一个真正的问题，我突然想到了，我爱你吗？
Or just New York City?
或者只是纽约市？